Hey, I've got a voicemail number
and you can call this number anytime you want the numbers to 192 david p a troll called in well someone I
Identified as a troll called in to say they are mostly not a troll, but they are sometimes a troll take a listen to this
Hey, David. I just watched you answer my question on the estate tax, and I want to say thank you for answering it
It was a very thorough answer, but I just wanted to say usually I'm not calling into your show trolling
I have less maybe three or four trolls before because I thought it was funny, but
Usually when I call in it is not a troll I'm have genuine answers, and I just want to say I watch your show every
single day
uuhh
I'm on your reddit all the time as well. Thank you. I love your program. I love the community that you built
When I call in and troll it's typically just good fun
And I just I don't know I did it just kind of makes me laugh sometimes
Oh, so I'll stop doing that okay, but usually when I call in it is genuine
Questions, so thank you for taking my question about the estate tax very very good no my pleasure absolutely and it's good to know that
This is only sometimes a troll so I was completely wrong and saying that this is always a troll it is only
Sometimes a troll because they think it's funny very very good on today's bonus show a Japanese company is giving their non-smoking employees
six extra days of vacation
To compensate for all of the five to 10-minute cigarette breaks that the cigarette
Smokers get what do we think about that is it some form of discrimination?
We will talk about it on the bonus show we also are going to talk about a new report that indicates that how your brain
Responds to certain particular words might predict your risk for suicide and the FDA is warning
Candy lovers too much black licorice could land you in the hospital is
Pat throwing out his two tons of black licorice that he just bought he will tell us on the bonus show
David pakman.com slash membership is one way to get access to the bonus show
Patreon.com slash david pakman show is another way and remember the David Pakman show now accepting cryptocurrency
see contributions david pakman.com slash
cryptocurrency for more information on that